devant nous c'est quoi c'est ta cuisine
c'est pas notre cuisine c'est carrément
la maison hein nous on a une maison qui
fait 4 m/ 2 on vit dans cet espace qui
est assez petit on va dire mais on vit
tellement dehors queon a pas besoin
d'être à l'intérieur on est très bien
ici mais certains diraient Mo je peux
pas vivre comme ça mais c'est pas grave
c'est nous qui vivons là l'histoire
depuis 6 ans c'est juste de m'installer
ici pour garer la caravane on attend
trouver quelque chose ou mettre et puis
je me suis tellement plu ici que j'ai
voulu rester donc je suis resté après
l'histoire c'est c'est juste de de
m'intégrer dans ce lieu et puis dire
mais ce lieu peut m'apporter plein de
choses pas seulement de la nourriture du
bien-être on m'a tellement fait croire
que je devais être quelque chose de
quelqu'un ou je j'ai juste envie d'être
un être vivant c'est quoi votre monde
Nomad
land c'est la vie moi c'est le nôtre et
que chacun crée le sien